have a good
yeah
have a good lesson bill
i hope everybody can see me welcome to
rational science and a little bit of
technical problem there
[Laughter]
can everybody see me and hear me
hopefully
[Laughter]
okay
okay folks first of all i got to tell
you i got a cold like a couple days ago
and i'm
somewhat recovering from that so if i
die here on the camera well you know
what happened okay
second thing is apparently there was a
problem with the ip address that's why
i'm a little late sorry about that
and the show must go on so let me go
forward
okay i'm going to start with this
scientific critic a fellow
who
made a video 45 minute video on about
seven of my videos he criticized my
notion of the scientific method
and i'm answering one
point at a time he just mentioned too
many
issues okay he brought up a lot of
issues and so i'm going to
address one issue at a time today i'm
going to address the issue that he
raised
it's related to
evidence
so let me get that uh video rolling uh
you're gonna hear him
uh with his own words you know he's
gonna tell you
what his problem is with evidence so
here goes okay
give me a second here let me turn it on
okay here it goes
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what is evidence and
does evidence play any role in science
for example he says that science is
about rational explanations and yeah
you'll have to have a hypothesis but
their hypothesis doesn't mean anything
if it doesn't align with the evidence
what bill doesn't seem to get is that
evidence is the important thing in
science not the hypothesis
let me run that one more time i got a
little behind on that so one more time
here for everybody who missed it
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what is evidence and
does evidence play any role in science
for example he says that science is
about rational explanations and yeah
you'll have to have a hypothesis but
their hypothesis doesn't mean anything
if it doesn't align with the evidence
what bill doesn't seem to get is that
evidence is the important thing in
science not the hypothesis
okay
so the issue is evidence okay he says
that evidence plays an important role in
science
but even before that we have the issue
of the word hypothesis
what the hell is a hypothesis he thinks
it's a an explanation he thinks a
hypothesis is a tentative
theory okay tentative explanation
so here's the rundown on uh how we
address that the first thing is that uh
in the religion of mathematics right
hypothesis is an explanation
in science a hypothesis is an assumption
assumption includes the objects you're
going to use you have to make an
assumption about the invisible objects
that mother nature father universe the
devil god whoever you believe in
what they use to do their physic their
physical things every day you know
they're ordinary uh working you want to
explain gravity you've got to figure out
what invisible
entities uh mother nature uses
to do this phenomena
and so
one of the things is that a hypothesis
includes the objects the other one
includes the definitions
you need to have a series of definitions
so that people can understand what
you're talking about okay
and then the other one is the what we
call the statement of the facts not the
facts
uh facts is what mother nature knows
he's got a file cabinet out there with
all the things that happened we have no
access to that file cabinet all we can
do is make a statement of what we think
is in that cabinet statement of the
facts we call it those form the
hypothesis those are three main points
of a hypothesis okay so we have a
problem there already we have a
difference with what this uh fellow
learned that uh harvard cambridge oxford
maybe saint andrews university
all these
are just monasteries they just teach the
same thing that they learned from the
previous generation
okay that's the first issue then we have
an issue of uh you know
here you have it uh
for example someone prevent presents
evidence they're going to present
evidence and what does the prosecutor do
he presents a feather
and you say where does he present a
feather well he's going to prove to the
jury okay this is the prosecutor he's
talking to the jury he's going to
present a feather and he says that
feather belongs to an angel
because he's going to say he's his
argument is that the angel cause gravity
okay and he presents evidence a feather
okay and here it is okay here's a
illustration of that here's you you have
the
uh prosecutor presenting a feather to
the jury because he says that
gravity or magnetism or whatever is done
with angels
okay now
is that good evidence
are we gonna accept that uh as part of
the theory of how gravity works
and here you have uh the modern version
you say well you don't believe in angels
fine okay do you believe in space time
okay here we have
warp space time
what is he gonna present
uh warp time
are we talking about here you know you
have uh gravity probe b
uh according to nasa's project
1970s
they say that they sent the probe out
there that had a gyroscope this
gyroscope uh supposedly
and here you gotta you know sit down to
really understand what they're talking
about they say that what the gyroscope
did was drag
space time around itself
okay they say they it was known as frame
dragging okay so here's here's a little
gyroscope and it's gonna drag space time
around itself
uh is that evidence is that the evidence
you're you're looking for to understand
how gravity works
okay so we have a problem because here
we these people are presenting evidence
maybe evidence of a you know a feather
or maybe warped time
and with that they're gonna say that's
the evidence that uh that explains how
gravity works out there
what sense does that make
and then we have another issue with
evidence and that's that evidence has to
do with belief
you know i present evidence what is the
purpose of that evidence
it's uh in
you know the purpose of it is to
induce you to change your way of
thinking i'm trying to recruit you to my
way of thinking that's what i'm doing
with evidence that's what a prosecutor
does that's what a priest does you know
he presents evidence maybe the bible or
whatever and says i want you to believe
like i do
that's what evidence is all about
i mean here you have the jury and they
convict a guy and they send them to the
gallows and it turns out 10 years later
because of dna or whatever new evidence
it turns out he was innocent or they
determined that he was not guilty
so what does that mean about the first
evidence was that evidence proof that
the guy was uh
you know guilty and now there's new
evidence that shows that he's not guilty
and again you can see that uh we have a
problem with evidence and then there's a
final issue there that you know what
evidence are you going to present for an
invisible intangible entity
an object is not that which you can see
or touch an object is that which has
shape you cannot necessarily see and
touch every object in the universe you
certainly cannot see the air
you cannot touch the table the klingon
has on the other side of the universe so
clearly see touch are
irrational uh criteria to define the
word object an object is that which has
shape and that does not mean that does
not entail that you can see and touch it
okay so now you have an invisible
intangible entity okay that mother
nature father universe whoever has out
there
what
what evidence can you present
please tell me give me a clue what
evidence i can present for an invisible
intangible entity that will prove to you
that will convince you that yeah that's
exactly how mother nature does gravity
so this is the issue evidence
is a problem okay it's a problem because
first of all it's got to do with belief
second
you cannot use evidence to elucidate the
nature of an invisible intangible entity
and then you know it's uh one of those
things that even if i present evidence
like you know in the case of the gravity
probe
project what am i going to do present uh
wipe time
what kind of evidence is that am i going
to present a feather to prove to you
that an angel
does gravity
so this is where the problem is so now
this fellow is uh mistaken
we do not present evidence in science
what we do in science we present a
theory an explanation of what of how we
think gravity works
and
the purpose is not for you to believe
the purpose is for you to understand it
and then you reach your own conclusions
in your own dark basement
that's the way science works
okay
okay moving on let's go with the subject
matter of today and that's the word
concept what in the world is a concept
it turns out that in the last 3000 years
nobody has defined what a concept is
they never define what an object is they
never define what a concept is and
that's part of the problem today you
know the way we look at it every word in
the dictionary can be divided or fit
under one of these two categories either
it's an object or it's a concept
what is an object an object is that
which has shape what is a concept it's a
word
that uh
embodies
or
includes in some way
refers to
two
objects
so we can say that um
an object is to one what concept is to
to
that's more or less
our argument today but before we can get
there we have to go back all the way
2500 years to the days of mr plato okay
and mr plato and uh not not the first
one by the way okay
apparently it goes even be before him uh
saying that pythagoras was really the
guy who came up with it we need to
figure out what philosophy is and the
reason we need to go back to philosophy
we need to know what the philosophy
deals with concepts like physics deals
with objects the bread and butter bread
and butter of philosophy is the concept
and so
uh philosophy and concepts are like you
know
love and marriage you know they go
together like a horse and carriage
that's more or less the situation there
so here we have mr plato and this is uh
his notion this comes out of his book
six
uh the republic okay
it says the nature of the philosopher
has to be a certain
obviously he's right now we have to
start out by figuring out what is
philosophy about what is a philosopher
okay and so he says philosophical minds
always love knowledge you know what does
philosophy mean for the love of wisdom
well love of knowledge love of wisdom
that's more or less the notion they had
says love knowledge of a sort which
shows them the eternal nature not
varying from generation and corruption
why corruption because you're going to
be dealing with philosophy in in the
context of politics that's why they will
never intentionally receive into their
mind falsehood
okay
and falsehood again is an opinion which
is their detestation and they will love
the truth
truth what is truth
opinion that's what truth is what is
truth to you is a lie to me
is there anything more akin to wisdom
than truth
so you can see he he goes this into this
issue of truth and again that's got to
do a lot with opinion if it's got to do
with opinion it's got very little to do
with science it's got to do more with
religion
opinion is religion you're you know what
your opinion is we we care
very little about in science science
only deals with objective not fact but
with objective explanation so that you
understand in the case of physics
physical interpretations okay in the
case of philosophy so that you can
understand
reasons and
purposes in other words behavior right
and now we can fit them under science
which is
explanation rational explanation okay
okay so so what happened here we have uh
another fellow his name was aristotle
and we have plato versus aristotle you
can see the differences they had uh
regarding what philosophy is or what a
philosopher is all about okay here we
have the differences between them we
have plato's philosophy okay and as the
philosophy of plato is more theoretical
and abstract in nature whereas the
aristotle philosophy is uh more
practical and experimental in nature
even though everybody today complains
that good old aristotle did not do
experiments okay
but anyways here we have plato's
ultimate happen happiness as dependent
upon society well uh aristotle said
dependent upon the individual okay so we
have uh
uh one person within in a society and
one person all alone that's essentially
what was the difference between plato
and aristotle
and then uh plato believed that man's
ultimate goal was becoming one with the
universe and i think that came from the
way back east
okay and uh aristotle instead said
ultimate goal was achieving excellence
and becoming a master
wisdom is the most important virtue and
the foundation of all good and embodied
all virtues virtues and that was uh
plato and instead uh aristotle said
wisdom is virtuous goal one could
achieve with effort and diligence and it
was not a virtue that appeared
automatically nor was it a unification
of other virtues
then you have the soul the famous soul
you know that's more or less where we
got these ideas in the western world
okay soul is the guide to body and mind
it is further divided the soul into
three
parts which are emotion desire and
reason
whereas aristotle said soul is the form
of a living thing and was inseparable
from the body okay
so we have a difference between these
two but what are the these two folks
talking about this is what their their
notion of philosophy was
and
you know i'm saying none of them has
anything at all to do with philosophy
and these are the two folks that gave a
kickstart to philosophy in the western
world that we live with even to this day
so when you have a philosopher out there
you know maybe you get to the
stanford encyclopedia philosophy what do
they talk about well they talk about
this kind of philosophy what they call
philosophy when you go into it you find
that it's all opinion it's all
recommendations they talk about what you
should believe in
how a government should be run whether
you should believe in certain religion
et cetera et cetera they do
recommendations that's all they do or
how you should be happy
is that what philosophy is all about
i mean
think about it for a second you know i
can give you my recommendations of how
to be happy uh how a government should
be run whether you believe in god or not
uh that's my philosophy
and you probably have a different
philosophy a different way of thinking
are we saying that there are 8 billion
philosophers on planet earth everybody
with his own
way of thinking is that what philosophy
is all about
if that's true then how can we
distinguish mr plato or mr aristotle for
many of us why do we say that they are
philosophers
i mean we're all philosophers for that
matter under that definition on that
under that notion of philosophy
so this is what's nonsense about the
notion we have a philosophy that we
inherited from the greeks okay
what is wisdom well here you have a
little definition that we found today
wisdom the quality of having experience
knowledge and good judgment
uh what's good judgment is it
some kind of difference
with bad judgment i mean what's good for
you it's bad for me maybe
i mean all these are opinions none of
this has anything to do with anything
solid that we can include under science
or that
you know if it's not objective who cares
about this notion of philosophy when you
say you study philosophy at the
university what the hell are you
studying
are you studying opinions are you
studying recommendations uh how to do
politics how do you do how to do
religion is that what philosophy is
about
hopefully philosophy is something a
little more uh objective
you know and not so opinionated
okay
here we have uh
the philosophy this is how this word
philosophy has developed even to today
here we have it philosophy the study of
the fundamental nature of knowledge
okay is that is that what philosophy is
knowledge what is knowledge well there
you see uh the equal sign knowledge is
equal to belief
that's what knowledge is when you know
something you believe it
and in fact mr plato essentially
summarized it is justified true what
belief
that's what knowledge is now they just
believe
we don't deal with knowledge or belief
in science we deal with explanations
objective explanations so there you see
it the study of fundamental nature of
knowledge reality and existence
absolutely not because philosophy
doesn't deal with existence philosophy
deals with uh
behaviors and existence is the exclusive
province of physics physics is the
science of existence physics only
studies you can say
i don't like the word study i'll say
that
physics only attempts to explain what
exists out there and how it works
and only
deals with existence
says especially when considered as an
academic discipline
philosophy this comes from the wikipedia
the study of general and fundamental
questions such as those about existence
reason knowledge values mind and
language again same nonsense what is
existence the ability of an entity to
interact with reality
it refers to the ontological property of
being what is existence what is reality
what is being they're all synonyms if
you look these words up reality uh is
defined in terms of being in existence
being is defined in terms of reality and
existence and existence is defined in
terms of reality and being
they're all the same words we haven't
learned anything because all of these
are synonyms what is knowledge belief
also a synonym so so far we know nothing
of what
knowledge is or what existence is to say
that philosophy studies existence is is
useless if you're not going to define
what existence is and nobody has ever
done that in the last 2000 years now
here you have our version okay science
what is it
rational explanations
if you're going to do physics rational
explanations of phenomena if you're
going to do philosophy rational
explanations of what behaviors
okay so physics deals with causes and
mechanisms philosophy deals with reasons
and purpose
uh the bread and butter of physics is
the object the bread and butter of
philosophy is the concept primarily okay
that's how we divide it
okay so as a result of uh mr plato and
his
co-religionaries the greeks
these are the branches of philosophy
that we ended up with today okay
you have aesthetics ethics epistemology
metaphysics okay logic mind and language
philosophy of science political
philosophy philosophy or religion what
is all this
i mean this this has nothing to do with
philosophy all this has to do with
opinion and opinion is not a branch of
science
opinion is a branch of religion
okay so we separate religion from
science and that's what we propose as a
new
version of science in this channel you
don't have to believe us
you take it for what what it's worth to
you okay that's the way we look at it we
don't care if everybody in the world
votes for it or against it it doesn't
matter one yoda okay
okay and uh finally here we have this is
the methodology we ended up with today
it's the choice of methodology is guided
by
epistemological considerations about
what constitutes philosophical evidence
how much support it offers and how to
acquire it and these are what you see
you can see i want you to
focus on what these people are saying
here you will see that they're all
opinions
methodological
skepticism what is skepticism means you
doubt something what is that that means
opinion
is a prominent method of philosophy
using systematic doubt what is doubt
opinion to determine which principles of
philosophies of philosophy are
indubitable what is indubitable opinion
common sense another method right starts
with commonly accepted beliefs what is
belief belief that's what it is just
opinion
which it often employs in a negative
sense to criticize philosophical
theories that are too far removed from
how the average person sees the issue
again opinion that's all it is various
methods in philosophy give particular
importance to intuitions
non-inferential non-inferential
impressions about the correctness
correctness what is correct opinion of
specific claims or general principles
these anticipated consequences can then
be used to confirm or refute what is
confirm a refute opinion philosophical
theories
pragmatists stress what the significance
of concrete practical consequences for
assessing whether a philosophical theory
is what true or false what is true or
false opinion
all of this has to do with opinion all
this methodology that they have today
so no philosophy if you study
philosophy at the university level
all you're studying is opinion
recommendations uh beliefs
that's got nothing to do with uh
objectivity first of all it's all
subjective and if it's not objective i
don't know how you can fit that within
science hopefully science is
objective so that it applies to everyone
on the planet a chinese an american a
russian a south american african and a
european
they should all reach the same
conclusion as far as if it's objective
now if it's subjective well everybody
you got a billion
opinions
so again philosophy
is a big problem because it has never
been defined and what is interesting if
you go to stanford encyclopedia of what
a philosophy the only word you won't
find before that's not defined is the
word philosophy
you would think that a
an encyclopedia philosophy the first
word they defined as philosophy so we
know what the subject matter is we need
to know what the discipline known as
philosophy represent or what it stands
for
we don't not if you go to stanford
encyclopedia philosophy which is
probably the number one
reference material out there in the
internet
okay so how do we relate this to the
word concept now we have velocity we
don't know what philosophy is turns out
the bread and butter of philosophy is
the concept that's why i know we do any
better
with the concept here we go okay here's
the uh
summary that uh good old plato had okay
we start with him again okay and this is
it it says uh this is just a summary
okay there is a realm of ideas or forms
which exist independently of the thinker
it is the ideas which distinguish mere
opinion from knowledge okay so he
thought there was a difference there
okay
material things are transient and liable
to contrary properties material things
can only be the objects of opinion i
don't know how he ended up with that but
that's how he concluded on the other
hand he says ideas in other words the
forms that he was talking about ideas
are unchanging
real knowledge can only be had of
unchanging ideas
okay so he would thought that ideas were
eternal that those were the ones that
maybe the gods knew about
and all we could do was relate to the
objects that we could see or touch which
is kind of interesting you know because
again he was a little more abstract than
good old aristotle
okay so um
because of mr uh plato how did we end up
today with this notion of the concept
what is a concept what the hell is that
and here we have us uh more or less the
what the notions we have today
concepts are defined as abstract ideas
take a hold of that word idea i'm going
to get back to that they are understood
to be the fundamental building blocks of
the concept behind principles thoughts
and beliefs
we're back to belief to opinion
in contemporary philosophy there are at
least three prevailing ways to
understand what a concept is oh goody
goody i'm i'm rubbing my hands i want to
see what this is all about first one
mental
representations entities that exist in
the mind
and they call it mental objects
so we have a mental object and that's
called a mental representation of
whatever and they can't think that
that's a concept they equate it with a
concept
what's the second one abilities
peculiar to cognitive agents in other
words what mental states
it means if you shoot up you know you
have a mental state
and that's an idea which is a concept
and then you have the last one abstract
objects
so they think again you have mental
objects now you have abstract objects as
opposed to mental objects and mental
states
okay so we have mental representations
which are the mental objects we have the
abilities and we have the abstract
objects those are what they consider the
the set of those three right are what
they consider concepts
things like numbers sets and
propositions are what abstract objects
they call them objects who calls them
like that the mathematicians those are
the ones who turn numbers into objects
and sets and whatever and they they talk
about
objects no they're not objects you have
to define the word object before you can
use it in a sentence like they did there
and so
what does the word abstract mean because
they're talking about abstract objects
abstract thought of part apart from
concrete realities specific objects or
actual instances
so what does abstract mean it's the
opposite of concrete what is concrete
the opposite of abstract
we don't know what abstract or concrete
are but they are antonyms and that's how
they're defined
so again an antonym is not a definition
it's a circular definition the fact that
you say that a cat is not a dog or not a
horse that does not mean that you
understand what a cat is
okay yeah a cat is not a tree not a
house not a rock i mean you can go
forever
so you cannot define a cat in terms of a
negative
and that's called an antonym and an
antonym is a circular definition so we
don't know what an abstract is so we
don't know what an abstract object is
because we don't know what an object is
and all that is what a concept is
you got it i hope you you understood it
okay and here is the word idea which i
asked you to retain for a second here it
is idea
any conception conception i thought a
concept was an idea now an idea is a
conception great any conception existing
in the mind as a result of mental
understanding awareness or activity
okay now we continue here and says a
little description here ideas are the
result of thought no kidding
ideas can also be mental
representational images of some object
absolutely not that's not an idea
thought a product of thinking idea or
notion what are we talking about we're
talking about synonyms conception what
is a conception a notion idea concept
what is a notion vague or imperfect
conception idea or some of something
so we have synonyms we we don't have a
definition for any of these words all
we're doing is running around in circles
just using synonyms to define supposedly
define
uh other words and yeah at the end of
the story people just say well you know
words require more words require more
words and all those words need to be
defined so we don't know how to define
any word in the dictionary right
not in science that's only in
mathematics not in science in science we
are able to define
the key words that form the foundations
of physics okay and one of those is not
the concept we do not move concepts
around we define it only to distinguish
it from objects what is an object an
object is that which has shape what is a
concept well you could say
just vaguely you could or very like rule
of thumb you can say that a concept is
that which doesn't have shape but that's
not the definition the formal definition
is an object is a word that embodies
or includes
two objects you need to defo you need
two objects to define a concept
meaning that you need to define the word
object before you define the word
concept a concept is a relation between
two
objects okay and here's a pictorial
representation of that
let me put it up here
okay there you have it object that would
just shape what is concept a word that
invokes or embodies two objects here you
have the first object a cat okay now if
you're going to talk about a concept
such as distance well hopefully you need
two objects and there you see a cat and
a dog okay now you can talk about
distance you can talk about direction i
mean try to define d try to imagine
direction without two objects or two
endpoints
a and b
okay and you can go on and on i'm
telling you the definition of the word
concept is that you need two objects no
other way of doing it
okay so what is a concept two objects
you can say or you can say that the uh
an object is to one what a concept is to
to that's a just a neat way of
memorizing that
so uh now you know what a concept is and
now yeah you can say that philosophy
is a
discipline that deals primarily with
concepts
okay whereas physics deals primarily
with objects now we can separate the two
and since both involve explanations in
one case explanations of physical
mechanism the other one an explanation
of behaviors purposes and reasons right
now we can fit them under science which
is what
a rational explanation
if it's irrational it doesn't even
belong to science to be good with
okay let's move on here we had a
case of the moonies okay
where the moonies
well the moonies are people who believe
that we never went to the moon we had a
lot of questions related to them and
they put the seed of doubt the other day
in my mind
only because i'm not able to explain
every aspect that i've seen okay it
doesn't mean that i don't think we went
to the moon but i cannot say that i can
explain
everything that uh they raised all the
issues that they raised okay
and here are some of them i'm gonna go
with some of the questions that or
issues that people brought up okay
here's the first one says armstrong
could be the first man on the lunar
surface okay why not says photographic
evidence necessitates the film crew
arrived in advance
[Laughter]
okay so we have to send the uh
the people from hollywood first before
we can send armstrong neil armstrong up
there you know because someone's got a
film
but when you look up uh you know how uh
nasa explains this which i think is
pretty decent okay decently explained
here is this says apollo lunar
television camera as it was mounted on
the side of apollo 11 lunar module when
it telecasted neil armstrong one small
step and there you have the link so
anybody can look it up and so
uh you know they're saying that the
first thing that
they had was a camera on the side of the
of the lunar module and obviously if
you're going to land the man on the moon
you're going to film them
i'm sure they took care of that problem
i don't think they went to hollywood to
hire some people to do this okay
so yeah
some people really take this a little
too far
and
again i think what people should really
do
is uh focus more on the iss the
international space station because it's
something that everybody can verify
today just get a pair of binoculars get
a telescope ask your friend if he's got
a telescope or whatever
and you have the schedule from nasa
and it tells you where the iss is
as it rolls around the earth it goes
around every
90 minutes 15 times per day you can
locate it with your telescope and you
can verify for your own self that this
monster is orbiting the earth way up
there 400 kilometers uh 250 miles out
there okay and you can see it with your
own eyes okay and uh so i did film uh
had this fella who filmed it okay
and i showed it a couple times already
so that's the first one you have to
verify because if that's true if you
verify with your own eyes that there is
an orbiting monster out there
you got to ask yourself how did that
thing get up there
did they just one day decide you know
overnight say oh why don't we send a
little monster out there to orbit the
earth and so you put two rockets on this
big monster right and you just send it
out into space somebody orbits the earth
no hopefully there were many steps taken
before we could send that thing up there
okay there had to be many steps
and if you're going to take many steps
like you know send a probe to orbit the
earth well maybe one of those steps
would be to send a guy like gagarin who
went out there and orbited the earth
himself and then he brought him back to
the earth
and if you can do that with something
orbiting the earth why can't you send a
probe all the way to the moon to venus
to mercury to mars
and i'm saying you know not uh
without trip with without people in it
okay
so you don't have to send anyone
in those probes all you have to do is
just send the probe out there you know a
robot essentially
so you know you don't risk anybody's
life or anything like that to say that
we never went out there that we don't
have the capability well i think that's
a
far stretch of the argument okay
okay now here's another thought he
raises another issue says when i saw the
astronauts jump allegedly on the moon in
the 60s i remember being taught that
gravity being much lower on the moon an
astronaut would be able to jump maybe
six times as high as on the earth what i
saw was a uh basically a normal jump so
that but a layer of doubt in that put a
layer of
yeah that put a layer of doubt in my
mind concerning there being actually
trip to the moon well there you see it
um
i can't remember who this was i don't
think if this is buzz aldrin or maybe
this is another
uh
trip to the moon or supposedly trip to
the moon
uh you can see the one on the bottom and
it's going real fast and the one on the
top is going half as as fast and so the
question here is yeah you could film
this on the earth in a
hollywood studio no no doubt about it in
my mind you could do this here on earth
okay
but
this is not a smoking gun because i
don't know how you could tell the
difference between the one on the bottom
and the one on the top
i can just as well say that this was
done on the moon as it was done in
hollywood i mean can you prove the in
the opposite can you argue on the other
side of my argument and say that uh this
was done on the moon if i say this was
done in hollywood or vice versa
and i don't think you could and again
i'm saying this is not a smoking gun for
anyone
and
here you have uh you know the
fella who answered him says obviously
something is wrong with your thinking
the apollo space suit uh with a life
support backpack was a combined weight
of 360 pounds on earth put that much
weight on and try to jump
they were able to jump on the moon damn
sure couldn't do it on the earth
and i think he's right i mean you know
this is this is a
the way you got to look at it if if you
put one of these things on your head you
know on your back can you jump here on
the earth with 300 pounds on your back
and so again you don't expect the guy to
jump six times as high simply because
he's on the moon you gotta find out what
he's got on his back one one issue and
the other one is he's in a suit he's
trapped he's in a prison in there you
know
he's trying to breathe there you know
he's got his uh tubes and his air uh
supply
you know i want you to go up there on
the moon see if you're gonna jump uh as
high as the moon
six times as much no way he's totally
right
so you gotta consider all these things
one fellow says uh spacex will make
lunar colonization a possibility with
the tech they are developing
there you have mr elon musk
okay and uh he's trying to get to mars i
guess
i don't think that's gonna happen i mean
we might make it but it's like
not like we're gonna colonize mars or
the moon uh there's no need to okay
uh what are we gonna do in the moon mine
the moon get some uranium out there and
just bring it to earth
you know how expensive that little rock
is going to cost
uh yeah it's going to be very expensive
so i don't think we're going to mind
them assuming assuming we could get the
equipment up there you know all these
cranes and so on i mean you know what it
takes to take all that to the moon just
to mine the moon put it on a little
probe and send it back to earth
the whole operation is just unthinkable
now that elon musk might
put a
tourist thing where they take some rich
people out there to orbit the moon
because they or orbit the earth in fact
to be out in outer space that could
happen of course that can happen what is
harder to think that uh that can happen
is that we're going to colonize the moon
or colonize mars
now there we're talking a big uh
that that's a big proposition i don't
think that's ever going to happen
okay
back to the iss here we have it uh
fell says sure
you can verify that there's something
that moves across the sky according to
the schedule presented by nasa which
they call the iss okay so this developer
believes that okay the iss is out there
fine what does he not believe well he
doesn't believe that there are people
inside the iss
he says but what's more much more
arguable is that what you see in the sky
shares an identity with the spaceship
that's shown in nasa's video supposedly
shot on board
and so
the the one on the upper right there you
can see the amateur he's filming the iss
from germany okay you can see it up
there in the sky anybody can look at
this with their binocular there he took
a picture of it so he says that's what
you see in the sky
and he says okay i believe that part but
he doesn't believe the one on the lower
right
and that's an astronaut and you can see
that his um laptop there is palm top is
floating
and i want you to produce that in
hollywood i really want you to i want to
see how you do that little trick okay
because one thing is for something to go
in fact i've got a let me let me show
you the water drop here okay because
someone raised that issue okay here it
is okay
you see that the lady up there the
astronaut
uh she's moving that drop of water and
then she swallows it okay
and and this file says well i saw that
in a movie and the movie he shows is the
one up below and you can see the guy
drinking the water drops that he um let
go of his can a little while ago so he
moves around but i want you to see the
drop the water drops they come in
straight
now that's just slow motion that's all
it is that's a slow motion water drops
being dropped from a can see he drops it
from the can the water drops flow and he
just drinks them that's different than
what the lady does
above okay she's doing something
different you can see the water drop
floating
now how did they do that they did it
with little uh wires
okay tell me how they did that trick so
these two tricks are not
identical okay this guy is just getting
this is just slow motion the guy on the
bottom that's all it is you can produce
i mean i can throw a bunch of water from
a can or from a bottle whatever
film that and then run it in slow motion
and that's what they did there that's
different than what the ladies doing
there okay
so no uh please show me
any uh
film
point to me to any film that shows that
kind of trick the one that she's doing
there what are they doing holding the
drops of water with a little string
okay so now uh i want to distinguish
those two it's not the same thing
what the lady is doing the astronaut
there with the guy on the bottom who did
it for a movie
okay let's move on to the questions that
people had today
for this week
and yeah i was i'm on vacation so uh
sorry guys
i had to postpone wednesday's class
first guy says
says uh the reason why the electrons
jump from the anode to the cathode is
not because they are pushed out of the
anode but because they are attracted to
the positively positively charged
cathode the analogy of shooting a man
out of a cannon is incorrect
it doesn't matter how much energy is
used to get the electron off the anode
it only has to be enough for it to
happen
then the electric field takes over to
accelerate it towards the cathode
well the problem with his whole
dissertation his whole paragraph there
is that he's making an assumption that
the electron is a little bead that
orbits the proton
that's what he's thinking
where did he get that that's the
planetary model that niels bohr and
rutherford came up with at the beginning
of the 20th century
and so he's he's accepting that as an
assumption okay
and i don't have a problem with that as
long as he can explain why the electron
doesn't
spontaneously fly away
from the atom i mean what keeps the
electron flying uh being faith so
faithful to the proton that's what i
want you to explain why doesn't the
electron fall to the proton which was
the question that led all these people
to do the research in the first place
and i always ask the opposite question
why does the electron spontaneously fly
out of the atom
until you can explain that you know you
don't have an atom if you don't have an
atom you know whatever you said there is
worthless you haven't said anything you
haven't uh explained anything you know
your atom is worthless please draw your
atom point to me point give me an uh a
url
address where i can see your atom so
that i can find out what your atom looks
like if it's if it ain't like that one
okay that's what i want to see
okay here's another fella he says talks
about my
unobservable ropes electromagnetic ropes
okay let's find out what he's got to say
says when you propose a mechanism to
explain why
you are appealing to human fallibility
well i don't know what this has to do
with fallibility or with humans this has
to do with proposing an assumption you
know you make an assumption about what
an invisible intangible entity you have
to make an assumption
okay i don't know if you understand that
but that's what you got to do
proposing an
unobservable entity phenomenon to
account for the why yeah you have to
make a proposal for an unobservable
you could make up anything such as your
electromagnetic
electromagnetic ropes or use some ether
okay okay
uh you can make up
you can't make up
an entity such an electromagnetic rose
what do you mean i can't make up i did
make up i made one up it's called the
electromagnetic row see how easy it was
i just made it up it came out of the top
of my head any problem with that
you've created an abstraction that is a
conceptual placeholder
for the actual mechanism that nature
uses
exactly that's what i did
we don't know what the actual one is
because only mother nature or father
universe or one of those guys knows
exactly what they use so i make an
assumption called an assumption okay and
i've created this one and i'm saying
it's the electromagnetic rope a pair of
twine threads okay
it's an assumption i'm saying if we use
that uh
entity as a mediator i can explain light
i can explain gravity i can explain
magnetism etc
that's how it works i want you to
understand the mechanism and the way i
get you to understand it is by
introducing the electromagnetic road so
i don't understand what um
what what your problem is with
understanding what i'm telling you but
i've got another issue and nasty says
you can make up anything
exactly you can make up anything and
here let me show you
let's make up anything in fact i showed
this the other day uh because i felt
this uh science uh fellow he criticized
this he said well i can come up with
green pixies
okay
i grant your green pixies i concede them
please explain the mechanism with your
green pixies and here we have it here we
have green pixies pushing from above
spoon is pushing the spoon from above
the ones on the right are pulling the
spoon from below
okay
now if you have another mechanism uh
fine i
i don't know i'm not smart enough for
all that right but here you have two
mechanism where the green pixies that's
what he came up with we have the green
pixies pushing from above and on the
right uh the green pixie somehow
whichever way pulling from below
now if you've got a different mechanism
i don't care if you use angels
introduce your angels i want to see your
mechanism please explain gravity with
whatever you come up with
so yeah you can come up with anything
people say well i can invent anything
yeah invent anything you want i'm
conceding anything you want just
whatever you come up with explain the
mechanism i want to understand how this
universe works i want to know how
gravity works i want to know why things
fall to the floor when i let go of the
spoon why does it fall to the floor not
to the ceiling
so if you can explain that
i don't care what you use use god if you
want
you know use anything you need i need to
see the mechanism
see you can bring you can bring god for
example right you say well god is all
powerful he's magic great no problem
and see suddenly the spoon falls to the
floor he says god did that great
tell me how he did it i want to know the
trick
if you cannot explain the trick it
doesn't matter if you produce god or the
devil or father universe you have not
explained the mechanism what are we
interested in physics in the mechanism
we need the mix okay
father talks about tangible facts oh man
religion can also exist i love his
wording
from we from with and to reality and
tangible experience whoa tangible
experience i need a beer for this one
the collective and longitudinal
experience of christians is not only
opinion but a validated fact
is tangible reality that must be
disproven by the skeptic
no no we don't disprove or prove
when you talk about proof and disprove
you're talking about religion you're
talking about belief what do you mean by
proof who are you proving to to the pope
to the dalai lama i mean who you who do
you prove to who's your interlocutor
okay who are you talking to who is the
guy who's going to believe you who did
you prove to
so no we don't use this proof or proof
in science that's religion
okay and that's what he says by the
skeptic
the atheist has a problem with science
not the theist this is why they now use
mechanistic encumbrances and will not
let go of disproven theories
uh well to some degree you're right i
mean
for sure the people in uh mathematics as
we call it mathematical physics
yeah they've proven everything for sure
and and then when you put them against
the wall and ask them questions they
have no answers
so in that sense i have to concede that
you're right on that one that's my five
cents worth
paul talks about a field
perhaps a field is just that a field
oh great i learned a lot a field is a
field
it's a substance
a fluid of something
a field is a fluid it's a substance
no let's
if you want to know what a field is just
look up the word and it says a value at
each point in space that's what a field
is
what is that you're talking about a
bunch of numbers followed by units at
each point in space at each each
location in space that's what a field is
it's the set of
values around uh ground zero that's
essentially what a field is
so you can't say that that's a fluid or
that's a substance
that's where you're wrong
the it's the mathematicians who have
turned field into a thing and they use
it as a paddle to push along charges and
who knows what you can't use it that way
okay so this is the problem the problem
is that they've turned field into a
physical object and you
all you did was parrot them and say well
it's a substance that's a fluid no it
ain't okay
a field is a concept it's a constant
that means a value at each point in
space that's a mathematical concept that
has nothing to do with
physicality meaning with physics
but saying it doesn't exist is
inaccurate only objects are said to
exist you can't say that a concept
exists and a field is a concept
a value at each point in space is not a
physical stand-alone object so you can't
say that that exists
okay
an electric field does exist no no field
does not exist no matter what the word
exists can only be used with physical
objects
physics is the science of existence it
only studies
objects
it does not study concepts
and a field is a concept energy is a
concept mass is a concept time is a
concept
you can't use any of those words and
substitu
treat them as physical objects
we can definitely feel it no you can't
you can't feel the feel
how do you feel a field
can you feel love
maybe you can i don't know even if we
don't know what it's made of yeah we
know what it's made of it's made out of
numbers and if it's made out of numbers
it you can't feel it i mean can you feel
the number five
okay so this is the problem people are
treating field as a as a thing
it ain't a thing you got to figure out
what is doing field you got to identify
the physical object that comprises the
field until you do that you don't have
an object all you're talking about is
the concept okay and it's very hard for
people to understand it yeah you take
two magnets you put your hand between
two magnets
and you don't feel anything you don't
see anything and yet one magnet
identifies the other one because
immediately it's attracted to it
or you know maybe repulsed by it
depending on which way if it's north
north south south not
and so the question here is you don't
see it you don't feel it but somehow the
magnet identifies the other magnet there
is something there we refer to that
region between the two magnets as a
field
but that's just the region that's the
concept that we field is the concept to
identify that region you have to
identify what physical object
mediates that region
and as i've shown in in previous videos
you can draw iron filings under water
with a magnet
one at a time because they come very
slowly to the magnet so something is in
motion in that region called the field
what you need to identify is what it is
that is moving in that region we called
a magnetic field in fact uh james
maxwell said it clearly and even before
that uh michael faraday
james maxwell said in that region that
it there is what
matter in
motion
matter in motion matter in motion please
remember that field is matter in motion
what you have to identify is the matter
that is moving
you can't say a field is a thing what is
the thing is the thing that is moving
inside the field that's what you have to
identify
okay
paul says i'll continue says to make
sense of an electric field i treat it as
a fluid yeah yeah you're making you're
making nonsense not sense
it's called nonsense okay
uncommon sense i would say
it's charge and discharge and not
ridiculous positive and negative charges
charge is a concept two there's no such
thing as charge
charge is one point six times ten to the
minus 19 coulombs that's what charge is
it's a number
okay uh
robert milligan determined that you know
he got a nobel prize for that okay so
no there's no such thing as charge
charge is a number a mathematical
concept so is field
these are just numbers turned into
paddles
treated as
physical objects
another fellow also talks about field
let's see what it is she says can't even
understand what a field is yeah sorry
about that i wish you did
a field is an energy's interaction with
energies in direction with material how
does energy interact with anything with
when energy is a concept
how does love interact with intelligence
please please show me the picture the
movie i want to see how they clash
regions of temperatures wind speeds when
watching the weather are fields
no no fields uh the only fields we know
are cotton fields
football fields those are fields
physical fields otherwise when you're
talking about magnetic or gravitational
fields you're talking about concepts why
because the definition
of field in mathematics mathematical
physics is
a value at each point in space until you
get that
deep into your head you think you're
dealing with an object you're not it's a
abstract concept mathematical concept
dynamic concept by the way okay there's
no such thing as a so-called static
field something is moving always within
a field
okay here we have existence is the
shorthand version for is
absolutely not okay
the word is
is a synonymous synonym essentially of
existence so there is no such uh
definition that we have today for the
word existence much less the word is
being
being
be to be you know uh those are synonyms
if you look up the word to be
you know the verb it'll say existence or
living that's what you'll find which are
all synonyms
object is that which i shape yeah good
this includes shadows and rocks
absolutely not rocks maybe shadow shadow
is not an object why because it's not an
independent
thing if you can call it thing it's not
independent
shadow is light that's how it is it's a
umbra or penumbra that's what it is you
stand in you need the tree to produce a
shadow without the tree there is no such
thing as shadow and all it is actually
is um just a wavelength of light that's
all shadow is
okay so it's just a question of
frequency
there is no standalone object called
shadow
and you say but it's got a shape no no
it doesn't that's not the shape shape
means stand alone
you know you have you have uh for
example when you have um
uh an angel
the halo
is not a stand-alone object if it's a
standalone object it's called a ring or
a plate
if you want to call it a halo it's got
to have the angel underneath it it's got
to be holy for it to be a halo the word
halo implies holiness
so there is no such thing as a
standalone halo halo requires the angel
likewise
a field you know requires a magnet okay
so you cannot have a shadow
shadow is a concept
why because you need two objects to
produce a shadow one of them is the
light source and the other one is the
tree or whatever you put in front
and
you probably need a third one which is
you know the screen on which you pre or
the
background on which you project the uh
the shadow
so no shadow is not a standalone object
and so yeah this fellow is mistaken yeah
it's that which has shape but you got to
be careful that the shape is a
standalone shape you know you have a
hologram hologram is just a shadow
that's all it is there is no standalone
object called hologram
okay so
just keep that in mind the context is
important here got to be independent
okay if l says physical existence in
other words existence as applied to
physical objects requires measurements
now we don't need to measure anything in
order for something to exist in fact uh
let's assume
just imagine right that there's a table
on the other side of the universe in the
land of the klingons
well that table apparently exists
well can you measure it i mean can you
tell me if it's one meter or one meter
and a half or how big it is
now you don't you can't measure it and
yet it exists why did
does it exist it exists by definition it
exists
if it meets the uh criteria or the
specification of the definition
what is the definition of exist
physical presence what does that mean
means object that has location
if the object has location it exists by
definition if god wants to exist he has
no problem all he's got to do is be an
object first a thing
that which has shaped and then he's got
to have distance with respect to me
god can decide to hide in the 26th
dimension for all i care there had
better be a line of direction from god
directly to me i don't care where he
hides
okay so if there's a line of direction
between god and me god exists by
definition not because i believe that
god exists it has nothing to do with
belief and certainly it has very little
to do with measurement i don't need to
measure anything if if if god exists you
know if god has physical presence if
there is distance between god and me if
there's a straight line of direction
from god to me god exists by definition
and i do not have to measure the angels
or heaven or hell
no measurement required
okay and nfl says object an identifiable
collection of matter which may be
constrained by an identifiable
boundary and may move as a unit by
translational rotation in
three-dimensional space
uh too lengthy first of all second
motion has to be defined after you
define an object so you cannot say that
an object is that which moves
okay because you first need an object
before you can talk about motion what is
motion well you have the definition
there change of position of what over
time or what of an object
assuming that were true but that's an
irrational definition because change
is already motion there is no such thing
as change without motion
so you can't use the word change to
define motion okay
space the boundless three-dimensional
extent in which objects and events occur
and have relative position and direction
now what is the
boundless three-dimensional extent
extent is a verb
okay that's what extent is in science
extent is a verb now in in ordinary
speech it's a noun but in science it's a
verb extent means you're going to extend
something extension okay it's like
motion motion is a noun in ordinary
speech motion in science is a verb
orbit is a verb an extent is a verb okay
so let's get those language the language
right for physics okay and so you can't
say that space is the boundless extent
okay nonsense
time length of change
length of
length like you know you're going to
unroll your measuring tape you're going
to
measure
the length of change
what is this okay and how can you do a
length of change you know
change in order to see change you need
to have two objects another way if
you're gonna
measure the change
you already have a measuring stick that
means you have two motions
or the interval which change occurs yeah
interval means that you're if you're
going to measure that then you have
already two motions okay and that's the
definition of time and exists having
objective reality and object an object
in space that even at its lowest energy
level have what fluctuations motions
changes uh no you don't have to move at
all in order to exist exist is the
static concept
okay so let's put those true definitions
side by side that you can see and
compare okay here's the definitions
object that which is shape space
that which lacks shape
okay
motion what is motion two locations what
is time to motions you require memory to
have time without memory there is no
such thing as time
and exist what is exist physical
presence what is that an object that has
location we're done that's how simple it
was all these years
and one thing to define words
scientifically you have to define them
as uh concise
as concisely as possible as short as
possible the more words you put in there
the easier it is to tear apart
so always put your definitions in as few
words as you possibly can
okay another foul says that we prove
objects let's see how what he's saying
here he says a sophist to prove that
some things are objects as opposed to
all things are necessarily objects
okay and so he goes through the
thought process the reasoning process he
says what hasn't dimension
neither has location
what has location
necessarily has dimension okay
what isn't real neither has dimension
nor location
what's real can share the same
attributes as what isn't real therefore
what's real has dimension and location
uh yeah essentially we don't need
dimension uh we're just going to say
that scott had to has to have shape and
location that's what's real real being a
synonym of the word exist okay but yeah
okay more or less the sophists were more
or less on the on the
on the same wavelength the problem is
that
even if they ever came close to defining
these words because aristotle already
had said that you know an object
has to have location in order to exist
but it went right through his brain and
out the door because he never used that
definition it's like he he he put it in
words but he never read his own words so
it's like he never discovered his own
definition and certainly he never used
it nobody ever used it after him either
nobody knows that an object that exists
it exists means an object that has
location
he called it place by the way
okay another foul says what object
doesn't exist
oh very simple the object that i'm
thinking about that doesn't exist see
how easy it was so there are objects
that don't exist you have an object like
a triangle that's an object in physics
because it meets the definition of
object it has shape
and no triangle exists
because it has no location what has
location is the ink and the paper or the
chalk in the board or whatever wherever
you drew it
okay if i said superman exists oh my god
let's see this fellow was convinced that
what can be observed exists okay the
wind black holes gravity etc okay so i
ask what about superman i can see him on
tv
and this foul says yes superman exists
since he can be observed
this is what the world has come down to
okay people who believe in religion call
science thinking that tv characters
exist
yeah
i feel your pain
superman exists folks they said as uh i
guess uh
green lantern
yeah
okay and another fella says let's see
let me get this higher bigger
uh the reason why the electrons jump
from the anode to the cathode okay i
already talked about this guy okay
first one that i mentioned
and let's get the last guy in here and
he says you're impossible pseudoscience
belief is a concept
no a rope is always an object a rope no
matter what here in the land of the
klingons it's always a thing
ropes are always objects
okay there's no no concept called rope
uh concepts are intelligence love energy
mass
time those are concepts
okay none of those have shape none of
those are standalone objects but a rope
you go to the hardware store ask them
for a rope they'll give you an object
that you can even see or touch even
though that's not the definition okay so
no and a rope is always an object so
they're not a concept so you got that
wrong and it's not a belief it's known
as an assumption
okay you make an assumption
let us assume let us assume assumption
right
let us assume that all atoms are
physically interconnected by ropes
very thin very tiny unseeable
untouchable ropes
okay
you make an assumption and from there
you can then later on say well let me
explain gravity to you now that i've
made that assumption that's how it works
is that a question of belief it's a
question of proposing an assumption so
that you can understand what i'm
proposing as a theory of how the
universe works
okay folks with that i hope to see you
next sunday i hope i won't have as many
problems i had today had my son here
help me out with this but we'll see you
on sunday and uh we'll see you then